jennifer lopez is getting closer to ben
affleck's daughters with the help of
some high-end jewelry i'm ready i'm
excited about it a source tells e.t that
lopez attended an event over the weekend
where the singer hand-picked out
necklaces for herself her daughter emmy
as well as affleck's two girls violet
and seraphina while checking out the
made by mary station the source said
lopez selected necklaces from the
brand's birth flower collection with
each piece corresponding to everyone's
birth month i want to give it away but
it has a very good ending
the source said quote jennifer mentioned
that she planned to gift violet and
seraphina the necklaces later that night
at ben's 49th birthday celebration
speaking of new bling lopez has been
sporting a necklace that simply says ben
lopez's gifts follow her recent night
out with daughter emmy and you guessed
it with ben affleck how's that amazing
last week another source told et the
trio enjoyed a fun family night out at
the restaurant craigs a high-end eatery
in beverly hills
the source added quote everyone was
getting along and they all seemed happy
to be there and max and emmy are getting
so big they're great they are they're so
big and so
amazing and happy lopez is mom to 13
year old emmy and twin brother max with
ex-husband mark anthony lopez became
engaged to anthony following her and
affleck's initial breakup in 2004. and
obviously i'm not going to talk about
anybody else's personal life but uh
but i'm i'm very happy for and i hope
she does great and while speaking with
e.t at the time affleck congratulated
the couple on their engagement and i
hope she's happy and i'm i i know she's
got a movie out i think this weekend
which is a great really good movie and
i hope that does real well
and
eventually she'll probably have an album
come out and i hope that does well so i
wish her and mark the very very best
meanwhile lopez and affleck have also
been seen doing some house hunting
around los angeles last month e.t
learned new details about their
resurrected love story i think we had
chemistry as actors from the first
moment we started working a source said
that their friends wouldn't be surprised
if they move in together and ultimately
end up together
affleck and lopez began dating in 2002
quickly followed by the couple
announcing their engagement we're trying
to get some can you see if we can get in
the papers
but in 2003 the wedding was called off
just days before their planned ceremony
in september and they officially called
off the engagement in january 2004 but
remained on friendly terms following the
split it was my first kind of heartbreak
lopez opened up about their breakup to
eat tea in 2014. i mean i had like a
puppy love heartbreak when i was like
12.
you know what i mean but i don't really
count that one it was my first like
adult heartbreak was it because it was
so public and we wanted to know every
single
thing about your relationship well that
didn't help
sorry
that didn't help but um no it was just
it was just one of those things you know
i was an adult we were about to get
married it didn't work out and it was
just
a bad heartbreak